[Music]
you play a character who you say is
based on Liam Gallagher from Oasis is
that right a little a little bit
visually visually visually this is
similarity we have a side by side
picture I'm the guy on the right you're
the one on the right I see do you do you
even know Liam Gallagher I have had the
pleasure actually this is a small story
oh okay
so I was in London there was a GQ award
that I received yeah and I said to my
wife I said listen I'm gonna make a joke
about Liam Gallagher and Liam galas
Gallagher is gonna be then she said do
not do that Liam Gallagher has a history
of violence I said then be ridiculous
anyway so I could you know be a good
husband I went up to Liam Gallagher
before the water and I said listen Liam
Sacha Baron Cohen you sleep or rather
and I said listen I'm gonna make a joke
about you is that okay and he said yeah
no problem you know I'm gon do it and I
said how are you how's it going with
your brother Knoll it goes I know he
goes I don't speak to him so I totally
forgotten about that anyway I went when
on stage and I didn't get round to
saying the joke cut to the after-party
later on he's sitting next to Bono on a
couch and I go and sit next to Bono and
Liam Gallagher looks at me and I've got
my friend XP and he goes and there's
some rude words in this pardon me
but he is and he goes you he goes who's
the greatest living rock star and so I'm
sitting next to Bono and Liam Gallagher
so I don't know who to say so I go I
know it's Stevie Wonder he goes
he goes Stevie Wonder you go Stevie
Wonder's popular he goes syphilis is
popular what I go actually syphilis
isn't that popular in yeah
and he goes cool which was nice and then
he goes he goes tell me who's a greatest
living rock star and so I again born Oh
Liam gotta go I go I don't know Bono
yeah and he goes no who's the greatest
living rocks I said I honestly don't
know
and he goes John Lennon and then my
friend says he's thinking about he goes
with John Lennon you said living he goes
John Lennon is alive and he stood up and
he goes I am John Lennon at that point
he falls over hits his head on the table
looks up and looks directly at me as if
I pushed him over anyway pretty Bono I
go I think I should go now and Bono says
stay right here yeah you're fine as long
as you're next to me yeah and so Liam
Gallagher that comes Matt he goes why
didn't you take the piss out of me
tonight I said part of me because why
didn't you say it's yoke about me
tonight you said you were gonna say a
joke and I said well I just didn't get
round to it because what I mean you
didn't get round to it and he then he
goes because you know what I'm gonna
stab you I said what he goes I'm gonna
stab you in the eye I said and I thought
to myself wow I've never heard such a
specific threat before it's one thing to
stab someone but to have that that's a
good day yeah yeah he didn't specify the
eye so he goes why didn't you say like a
well I never got round to you know that
bit of it I go you know when it's when
you like have a set list it goes I don't
have a set list I'm
rock star I go I go well in my career he
goes career career and I said Wow okay
he's Pleasant guy I've ever heard of I
said I came not career but my series of
performances and anyway eventually he
didn't stab me so I thought I would
avoid confrontation by having my hair
done like him in the next step
[Applause]
you